good afternoon I'd like to welcome all
of you to the second presentation in our
2017 laureate lecture series for more
than a decade this series has featured
talks by some of the most accomplished
scientists from across the country and
around the world today is a good
reminder that such scientific excellence
exists right here in our own community
as we welcome dr. subra Suresh president
of Carnegie Mellon University if you
read his guest column in the
post-gazette yesterday you already know
this but it bears repeating suber came
to this country as an immigrant's he
arrived as a 21 year old man from India
with a one-way airline tickets purchased
on alone a half empty suitcase and less
than a hundred dollars in cash based on
this very inauspicious beginning nobody
could have predicted the outcome a
doctorate from MIT and a stellar career
in material science and engineering
discoveries that have advanced human
knowledge and are helping this nation
live up to its promise and unanimous
confirmation by the United States Senate
to the role of director of the National
Science Foundation we're fortunate to
have super hero there are more robust
partnerships between piss and CMU then I
can hope to name but they include the
Center for the neural basis of cognition
which integrates pits and CMU strengths
and basic cognitive and computational
neuroscience the medical scientists
training program a highly successful
dual degree program funded by the
National Institutes of Health through
which students earn a medical degree
from kiss and a PhD from the basic
science or an engineering department
either a kiss or at CMU and the great
many other close collaborations between
individual labs and investigators
including subra and members of our
own medical school faculty it's fitting
then that dr. Suresh recently added a
University of Pittsburgh title to his CV
as of 2016 he is our medical schools
21st century professor of biomechanics
in medicine Subaru's research epitomizes
interdisciplinary science and that it
spans the fields of engineering
technology and biomedicine he's an
innovator and materials design who also
explores the nano mechanics of
biological cells and human disease
Subaru his bachelor's in mechanical
engineering from the Indian Institute of
Technology in Madras he received his
master's in mechanical engineering from
iowa state university and the year the
doctorate at MIT in just two years he
completed postdoctoral research at the
University of California Berkeley and
the Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory he began his independent
academic career at Brown University
where he was honored by the White House
and the national science foundation with
the presidential young investigator
award at the age of 29 he joined the
faculty of mi tease material science and
engineering department in 1993 he became
head of that department in two thousand
and he was named Dean of MIT school of
engineering in 2007 in 2010 dr. Suresh
became director of the National Science
Foundation upon his departure from the
NSF three years later President Obama
described them as a consummate scientist
and engineer beholden to evidence and
committed to upholding the very highest
scientific standards a CMU president
subra now the Rex one of the world's
leading educational and research
institutions whose scientific
achievements are internationally
renowned but he has earned many honors
himself and he is one of only 19
americans with membership in all three
of the
National Academies the National Academy
of Sciences the National Academy of
Medicine and the National Academy of
Engineering but today it is our honor to
host them for this lecture please join
me now in welcoming dr. subra Suresh to
deliver his talk study of human diseases
at the intersections of engineering
sciences and medicine
[Applause]
Thank You Dean Levine for your very kind
introduction it's a great honor and a
privilege to come and have this
opportunity to present a technical
lecture at the medical school at the
University of Pittsburgh even before i
came to pittsburgh three years ago I
knew quite well how celebrated this
institution is and after coming to
Pittsburgh I've had the extraordinary
pleasure of working closely with a
number of colleagues from the University
of Pittsburgh as well as from the pit
medical school I would particularly like
to single out to people with whom I've
developed very close collaborations in
the last three four years one is dr.
greg kadel hematologist at UPMC and the
pit medical school who's here and also
dr. yew'll Sadowski who's here who's the
head of the magee-womens Research
Institute in Pittsburgh it's been a
great privilege to be part of this and
i'm also very grateful to aunt Lavina
and to chancellor Gallagher for their
not only strong desire for collaboration
between the two institutions but also
their wang and and welcoming me not just
a Pittsburgh but also to the broader
intellectual community of Pittsburgh of
which university of pittsburgh plays a
major role so thank you very much I've
been extraordinarily fortunate to
benefit from collaboration with a large
number of people you will see and
especially in light of the angst at
pretty much all american universities
these days with respect to the talent
pool that may be impacted aided in
reality or in perception by some of the
directions in which we are heading one
of the things you will see you'll see
names of people who have contributed to
what I'm going to talk about I'm just
presenting all of their collective work
and without them this work would not
have been possible I would also like to
start by singling out one individual who
is being part of every piece of work
that I'm going to present for the last
15 years that has been done in my
research group whose I'm very glad he is
here with us today and that's the doctor
ming dao who's sitting here who's been a
collaborator in this work for for many
years and when I was at the NSF he ran
my research group for three years so
Thank You Ming for coming what I would
like to do is to start with a question
am I art mentioned in his introduction
I'm an engineer by training so many of
you especially a number of people within
clinical medicine are probably wondering
what are you doing here and so as a
wanderer into the field of medicine
about 15 years ago we asked the
following question my background is
mechanical engineering and over time my
work moved from macroscopic properties
of materials to nanoscale properties of
materials so in 2002 when I was head of
the department of material science and
engineering we created a nano lab and I
had a colleague of biologists a very
celebrated biologists who came to that
event and he said why are you working in
dead materials you should be working in
living materials I thought it was a very
insightful suggestion and then few
months later when I met him he said
you're not going to excite me with all
the fancy stuff unless you show me what
impact it has on human health or disease
so I thought that was a very insightful
comment so taking his criticism or
comment into account that's what steered
us in this direction so we asked the
question how can I bring my expertise
from a very different field especially
at 22 human diseases fortunately we were
also at the right place at the right
time for example you know that in two
thousand
president clinton launched the national
nanotechnology initiative at Caltech and
we had one of the very first nanos
centers that I was lead PIL so how to
apply nanotechnology the human genome
project was in full swing in the early
2000s so gene modification knocking out
of specific genes what impact does it
play experimental nano tools enabled us
to enabled us to take single biological
cells and molecules and probe them in
ways in which we could not have done
just a few years earlier in parallel
with all of this we had major revolution
in computation and computational biology
both with respect to hardware and
especially with respect to software and
more recently into mobile devices so if
you put all of this together all of this
was accelerating significantly in the
early part of the twenty-first century
about 10 15 years ago that's when we
started this work so we asked a
fundamental question the motivation for
this work two related questions both
forward and reverse problems how do
properties of self this is what
engineers focus on this is what material
scientists focus on the material science
is a field that is the interplay among
making materials of processing
properties performance and function and
microstructure and taking the same
paradigm to biological cells and
molecules what contributions can we make
especially at the cell and molecular
level so that's the question so the
first question in the forward problem is
how to change its insult properties
influence diseases the reverse problem
is how to diseases influence sell
properties so we have origins of
diseases that we don't know about such
as cancer we know origins of certain
diseases like infectious diseases such
as Plasmodium falciparum malaria we have
diseases where we know the precise
genetic origin such as sickle cell
anemia
and in the sixth position of the amino
acid if there is a defect you get a
sickle cell trait or a sickle cell
disease so given that broad spectrum of
things can we pick broad classes of
diseases where we can focus on the at
least a partial answer to these
questions and use computational tools
the latest tools in nanotechnology and
the latest tools in experimental work
across disciplines can we bring them
together and in each of these topics we
absolutely make sure that we have a bona
fide biologist and a bona fide medical
doctor or a scientist who can keep us
honest and keep a straight so the goal
would be of course to understand nature
that's the first major goal but of
course can we use that to improve
Diagnostics therapeutics and drug
efficacy assays so we have done a lot of
different things I'm going to focus on
three broad areas not necessarily in
this order different types of human
cancer at the cell level how can we
bring the latest tools from physics from
biology from material science from
different branches of engineering
Electrical Engineering microfabrication
etc computational biology to improve our
understanding of disease Diagnostics
infectious disease so cancer as one
major class we've looked at different
types of cancer plasmodium falciparum
malaria the most lethal form of
knowledge so the two common variants of
the Plasmodium in for humans is
Plasmodium falciparum plasmodium vivax
malaria where falciparum causes most of
the mortality currently several hundred
people per year die from malaria mostly
children with underdeveloped immune
system and the two most common forms of
malaria are placental malaria and
cerebral malaria hereditary blood blood
disorders and especially genetic factors
influencing
level properties and how they influence
disease state pain management and
therapeutics sickle cell disease is a
very good example of this so these are
three case studies that I would like to
take to walk you through so that the
talk is not just or is it very general
at a high level but there is also you
can see some of the potential
implications of the work so I'm going to
start with a first video there will be a
series of videos the first video not yet
thank you me the first video I want to
give a little bit of introduction let's
take cerebral malaria as an example why
is why of mechanical engineering
important so every second our bone
marrow produces hundreds of thousands of
red blood cells a red blood cell a human
red blood cell is about eight
micrometers in diameter it's like it's a
disc-shaped eight micrometers is
one-tenth of the thickness of the human
hair to scale it so if you take a piece
of human hair one-tenth of the thickness
is that the large diameter one red blood
cells the smaller diameter is 2
micrometers and the thickness of the
membrane is a few nanometers and inside
that you have hemoglobin and it doesn't
have a nucleus and it has a
two-dimensional cytoskeleton and so it's
the simplest form from an engineer's
perspective to model and forty-two
percent of the volume of blood in our
bodies is red blood cells that's why the
color of blood is red so where does
engineering come in this one tensor for
human has thickness red blood cell as it
navigates to the body to deliver oxygen
to distant parts of the body and take
carbon dioxide back to the lungs it has
to navigate through small openings in
the body two of the smallest openings
are the small blood vessels in the brain
who's in the diameter is or as small as
two to three micrometers and the
smallest fitness test for the red blood
red blood cell in the human body is in
our spleen the inter endothelial slip
a very small diameter very small opening
and the red blood cells to squeeze
through this that's the fitness test for
ever for the cell so an eight micrometer
disc has to scream squeeze through a two
to three micrometer tube to deliver
oxygen and car and take back carbon
dioxide and it has to do it millions of
times during its course course of
survival in the human body over a period
of 120 days this is what mechanical
engineers call fatigue back and forth
stretching and going back the cell
stretches by more than hundred percent
and come back and this is not new in the
medical community in fact if you go to
the malaria literature since the 1980s
microbiologists and parapsychologists
have talked about deformability so the
reason we decided to get started in this
was if parapsychologists can talk about
deformability somebody who does
deformability for a living should be
able to talk about parasitology so go in
the reverse direction and that's what
brought us to this problem in the first
first place so what I'm going to do
despite all the advances in medicine we
still don't have visualization tools as
a red blood cell which is a disk shape
goes through a small blood vessel in the
brain how does it deform so if you look
at textbooks in biomedical engineering
they will say a disc-shaped red blood
cell takes the shape of a bullet as it
goes through a flexible tube in the
human body and then when it comes out it
springs back to its initial shape so the
first video that I'm going to show is an
in vitro demonstration of how a live
human red blood cell will navigate
through a small blood vessel in the
brain it's an in vitro demonstration it
doesn't have the right chemistry doesn't
have the right biology but it has the
right geometry and it has the right
mechanics without without the right
chemistry so this is the work of a
former graduate PhD student of mine
david quinn who's here who's now at now
at CMU and this is part of his PhD
thesis work so before you click it one
more thing so as you see on your left
hand side
so this is blood human blood which we
use to obtain every week from the blood
bank that's it for all the diseases all
the protocols you send it through a
microfluidic device made of a polymer
called PDMS which has an inner cross
section which is exactly the same as the
cross section of a blood vessel in the
human human brain and what you're going
to see is a disc-shaped red blood cell
as it squeezes through the tube and
narrow tube takes the shape of a bullet
when it comes out at the other end it
springs back to its original shape this
is what our red blood cells do
repeatedly millions of times during 120
days in the body that's what you see in
the video this is the high-speed camera
you can we can slow this down it's like
you're a mechanical engineer there is
billion more pieces of information in
this that doesn't mediately beat the eye
for example you can slow down the exit
you can do a viscoelastic modeling you
can actually take that time we take you
can look at the time it takes for the
red blood cells to spring back to its
shape you can calculate the
characteristic time of relaxation which
for a human red blood cell is 300
milliseconds so if you know that time
frame you can verify that through
independent techniques so you can
calibrate your experiments so there are
many different details that I won't go
into thank you so now you see what
happens and you can see there in the
middle as the red blood cell goes
through it takes a bullet shape on it
springs back the human hike I cannot
quite capture it takes 300 milliseconds
for it to come back it's a validation of
the experimental technique so this is
the place where we started now let me go
to the first disease that we will
address an infectious diseases pretty
lethal infectious disease malaria
plasmodium falciparum malaria the the
history of malaria in the human body
starts with the mosquito the vector when
female Anopheles mosquitoes are pregnant
they need protein to nurture the eggs
they feed on human blood for the protein
if the person being bitten has the
gamete for malaria it goes
to the gut of the mosquito which
processes it in the so-called sexual
cycle of malaria in the mosquito in the
vector when the mosquito feeds again on
the human skin she injects tiny
particles called sporah sites
approximately 1 micrometer thick those
poorer sites go to the human liver the
liver processes that over the course of
seven days or so and then sends it into
the bloodstream that begins in the human
body in the bloodstream a cycle a
so-called electrostatic stage or a red
blood cell stage which lasts exactly 48
hours so a particle or a precursor to a
parasite meh reside with a sharp tip
called apical prominence targets
chemically targets the human red blood
cells it pokes into the red blood cells
so the particle is 1 micrometer the red
blood cell is 8 micrometer disk it folks
into the cell we have hemoglobin liquid
inside in a soft sac it gets inside the
red blood cell the cell feeds of seals
itself it's a beautiful engineering
problem that we cannot mimic we cannot
mimic nature and if one micrometer
object folks into an eight micrometer
disk no fluid spills out and the South
feels itself and while the parasite is
in the cell it's in a cocoon it's
protected from the immune system of the
body then it starts to transport
proteins to through the hemoglobin to
the cytoskeleton to the phospholipid
bilayer membrane and that causes
geometric changes at the nano scale so
in the first 24 hours the so-called ring
stage changes take place in the second
stage you form nano scale knobs on top
of the red blood cells then after about
36 hours the cell becomes so stiff and
so sticky that after 48 hours the cell
ruptures the single parasite inside the
red blood cells can multiply into many
parasites undergo nuclear division when
the parasite spill into the bloodstream
the immune system tries to fight back
and raise the body temperatures
you know the febrile episodes in malaria
they are associated with this mechanical
phenomenon of rupture so when we take
this the question is as the as the
proteins get transported to the red
blood cell what are the changes in the
properties of the red blood cell and
what their implications are according to
the microbiology community there are two
major effects that that other pathogenic
basis of malaria in humans one is the
stiffening of the cell the other one is
the increased stickiness of the cell
both the stiffening and the stickiness
make it difficult for the red blood
cells to go through peripheral blood so
they can be cleared by the screen if
they can get to the spleen and so that's
one of the key reasons why the severe
forms of malaria you get cerebral
malaria lack of oxygen to the brain so
trying to understand from a mechanical
perspective these origins so these two
are both mechanical factors according to
the microbiology community at the time
we started this work based on
instrumentation and tools that were
available the prevailing notion was the
amount of stiffness of the red blood
cells during the 48 hours was a factor
of 2 to 3 compared to a healthy red
blood cells what I'm going to show you
shortly is with more sophisticated
advanced tools what we find is that it's
not a factor of 2 to 3 is much more than
a factor of 10 even without
understanding the underlying mechanisms
that has major implications for example
some of the malaria patients also get
blood therapy that is often given to
stroke patients to improve blood flow
one of the drugs is pentoxifylline and
what is the role of what kind of dosage
to do you give to enhance flow to
counter increase in deformability and
saito adherence is that has never been
explored experimentally so what kind of
drug dosage do we give based on
perceived effects in the human body we
can try to address with
more advanced techniques so this is
where this is the motivation for us to
take up malaria as a first study about
12 years ago so we were very fortunate
to work with the medical school at the
National University of Singapore and
also with institut pasteur in Paris
where I had the good fortune to spend a
sabbatical in 2004 in the middle of a
malaria group and hematology group one
of the benefits of that was right at
that time the institut pasteur people
have successfully cloned the Plasmodium
falciparum parasite and they were also
able to knock out based on their field
work in Africa they were able to
identify one particular protein called
Risa ringing its ringing infected
erythrocytes surface antigen from the
parasite and we could look at what is
the role of that one protein based on
gene knockout on deformability and
stiffness we were not only they were not
only able to knock it out they were able
to knock it back in which gave a very
good control condition for a scientific
experiment so the experiment that i'm
going to show here is the work of
another PhD student john mills who
happens to come from pittsburgh he was
buying former graduate student what you
see here on the top is a healthy human
red blood cell and here is the challenge
for to do an experiment from a physics
or an engineering point of view you have
a live human red blood cell that you
have to keep alive in a
phosphate-buffered saline solution and
you have to immobilize the cell you have
to keep it alive the cells diameter is
micro scale it's eight micrometers or
the tenth of the thickness of the human
hair but the force that you need to
deform the cell to a level that actually
happens in the human body as it goes
through small blood vessels varies from
one picot Newton to about 100 250 Pico
Newton's so just to calibrate what a
Pico Newton is if you take an average
size Apple
and hold it in your hand and stand on
earth the force on your hand due to the
weight of the Apple is 1 Newton after
named a price that Newton a picot is 10
to the minus 12 which is one thousandth
of one billionth of one Newton the
weight of an apple on your hands that's
the level of force if the force was any
higher and if you have billions of red
blood cells in the body will feel it the
fact that we don't feel it the force has
to be very small so the challenge of the
experiment is how do you do an
experiment with a Pico Newton force
micrometer level displacement and still
keep the cellar life and make the
measurement accurately fortunately for
us we resort to a technique well known
in physics called laser optics or laser
tweezers this was a work for which
former energy secretary Steve to God is
a Nobel Prize in 1997 in physics so this
we can apply to this so what you see in
the top and using laser tweezers I won't
go into the technique you take to high
refractive index glass beads
functionalize them and attach them to
diametrically opposite ends of a human
red blood cells they serve as handles
just like you do a material experiment
then you can shine a laser beam on the
two beads and precisely you can clap the
bead if you move the laser beam the bead
will move with it as you move the bead
you apply a force and you use a standard
tool called Stokes law in mechanical
engineering to calibrate the experiment
and this has been done over and over
again in many different communities we
applied this to the case of malaria and
human red blood cells so in the top top
left figure is a live human red blood
cell attached to the beach no force the
middle figure in the top is a constant
force of 68 plus or minus 10 Pico
Newton's you stretch this out in a very
controlled manner and you can see how
the red blood cells stretches then we
increase the force to as high as 150
Pico Newton's plus or minus 15 Pico
Newton's and we stretch it further it
stretches further if you let the laser
go the cell
spring back to its original shape as you
saw in the video the same healthy human
red blood cells in the bottom figure now
you can see there are malaria parasites
inside that so the Left figure top and
bottom top is no parasite bottom is with
parasite no force the middle figures 68
Pico Newton's in the top 68 Pico
Newton's in the bottom except at the
bottom one as a malaria parasite even
with 68 Pico Newton's it loses its
ability to stretch if you now move it to
150 Pico Newton's it still has no
ability to stretch so we can do a lot of
computational biology on this and based
on that we can come up with predictions
of what they what is the extensive
stiffening or the reduction in
deformability so we found that it can be
as high as 10 to 100 contrary to what
was believed before based on cruder
techniques where it was believed it was
maybe a factor of two or three so that
was the first outcome of these
experiments so the next question is what
does it being for safe cerebral malaria
how can we demonstrate it I mean
obviously we can't image at the cell
level at a single blood vessel in the
human brain what is the effect of this
change in deformability on potential
consequences for the progression of the
disease so this is an experiment that we
did a few years ago this is again a
microfluidic device is the cocktail
glass shaped device with a long stem so
what you see let me see if I can I have
a better laser pointers Philippines so
what you see here is that not yet me let
me just stop it stop there that's why so
what you see here this particular cell
and this particular cell each has a
malaria parasite in this everything
around it is healthy so based on what I
showed you earlier these two cells are
now too stiff because of the parasite
they cannot squeeze through the tube all
the other cells around them should be
able to squeeze so that's the hypothesis
let's see if that works thank you so you
can see these two salt here and we're
going to add more cells around it
shortly stop it can you click it again
okay just leave it thank you so you can
see a whole bunch of cells they can all
go to accept these two suppose you get
10 of these cells blocking an entryway
to a particular blood vessels the
outcome could be very different so this
is there is no chemistry here there is
no biology here purely mechanics so the
next slide is so we know that how much
can you push this so here is a sort of a
dream question can you take a drop of
blood put it into a device that's about
the size of your thumbnail and just a
drop of blood can you answer the
following questions that somebody have
malaria do they have fever because of
malaria do they have plasmodium
falciparum malaria do they have
Plasmodium vivax malaria because the
mortality rates are very different what
is the parasitaemia what fraction of the
red blood cells are infected with
parasites quantitatively because that's
an indicator of the quantitative
indicator of the progression of the
disease what I think so so this is some
that's the question can we answer it
with a microfluidic device this is the
work of a group of students and
colleagues in electrical engineering
that we publish hanson bo was a student
like go supervise who got so excited by
this line of work after getting a PhD in
electrical engineering he joined the
johns hopkins medical school to get an
MD degree
and he'll be about 55 by the time he and
it is all it's always raining but this
is what he wants to do so what I would
like to show here is a series of
experiments to address that question so
we have a diamond-shaped obstacle we
have our data triangle-shaped obstacle
with a converging flow or a diverging
flow we send live human red blood cells
there so the speed with which the self
go through the obstacles for a given
pressure differential not only tells you
whether you have malaria or not it tells
you whether you have plasmodium
falciparum malaria which affects all red
blood cells are Plasmodium vivax malaria
which affects only young red blood cells
curricula sites which have been released
by the bone marrow within 48 hours of
release from the bone marrow it also
quantitatively can tell you how many
cells are infected purely from this
obstacle course experiment so thank you
so this is an example of an obstacle
course that you can create for red blood
cells and there is a lot of information
so the gist of this experiment is just
what I summarized just now so that's the
first case that I want to demonstrate on
the role of in this case physics and
engineering in shedding light on cell
level disease for for a infectious
disease I want to take a second problem
again physics plays a very important
role this is the work of a former
graduate student who worked with me
young Coon Park ballpark with me and a
professor of physics dr. the late
Michael felled and this is in the
spectroscopy lab at MIT the work
involves the following hypothesis it's
been known for a hundred years that all
living cells flickr fluctuate or vibrate
and that's been known through p read
through a variety of the
chemically active they are biologically
active in some cases they are
electrically active so matter goes in
and out of the self and they respond a
vibrate and it's been postulated for a
long time through work at Weitzman
Institute in Israel in Munich Technical
University of Munich the new york blood
center and many other places that the
flickering the level of flickering is an
indicator of health or disease at the
cell level unfortunately it was not
possible to get full fields so the group
ated narla mohandas at the New York
black center he did a series a wonderful
experiment where he where he looked at
one part of the cell and found that
things like ATP which is a chemical
currency can have certain effect and
there is flickering the group in Munich
which is also a highly reputable group
looked at it at a different part of the
cell and they found that there is
flickering but the effect of eight ATP
is exactly the opposite of what narla
found so both are correct but the
conclusions are somewhat mutually
contradictory so if one is wrong one is
right what is the technique part of the
problem was the native group could look
at full field and here is the problem in
doing a full field experiment the entire
self again you have to take an eight
micrometer cell immobilize it keep it
alive in a saline solution you have to
have a non-contact experiment the amount
of membrane flickering is nanometers so
thousands ten thousand times smaller
than the thickness of the human hair
that's the amount of vibration and the
timescale of flickering is a millisecond
and you have to do the full field and
it's a geometry a geometry issue because
it's a disc with a dimple in the middle
so how do you do this experiment it
turns out that physicists always knew
how to do this experiment except that it
wasn't tried for this for the biological
self so we decided was having a
exceptionally smart student is that they
quickly figure out how to do this so
here is a simple concept I
one going to the details of this and I'm
here is a simple concept so if you send
a laser beam of a certain wavelength it
caused so-called plane wave and here is
a human red blood cell that immobilized
the does hemoglobin inside the
hemoglobin has a certain refractive
index just like a piece of glass our eye
glass outside the cell we have
phosphate-buffered saline solution which
has a different refractive index so as a
wave goes through the salad then comes
out the difference in refractive index
between inside the cell and outside the
cell causes something called a phase
shift we can capture that electronically
digitally that phase shift is captured
by this function called delta fee which
we know from the experiment we know the
wavelength of light and we know Delta n
which is a difference in refractive
index between inside and outside the
south so if you know Delta n if you know
the wavelength if you know the phase
shift at any point you know the height
of the cell or the thickness of the cell
to a resolution of a nanometer and you
can do that for the whole cells and you
can do it at a millisecond time step so
problem solved so we did that experiment
so the advantage would be that with this
experiment we could take a live human
red blood cell any Cell in this case a
red blood cells a healthy cells we can
shine a very low-power laser beam on the
cell outside the human body for a very
short period of time just from the
membrane flickering quantitatively we
could tell you whether the cell is a
healthy cell or a disease so now I can
put a malaria parasite inside there I
can tell you whether the parasite is in
the ring stage trough side stage or
ashes on stage and we can do that for
other types of cell non-contact so I'm
going to show you a video that
demonstrates first for a healthy cell
then for an infected cell in the next
slide and so what you're going to see in
this video is purse the membrane
flickering in a color contour for itself
that during the course of 48 hours
you'll see how the cell is they
destroyed and how that's reflected in
the flickering of the membrane thank you
so the top is the time clock in
milliseconds this is a flickering in
height vibration this is the ring stage
that's the soft side stage late ring
stage and then the choice on stage which
is close to 36 to 48 hours you can see
how the cell is destroyed there is a lot
more information in the published papers
and what I'm presenting in the interest
of time so you can actually get the
signature of these waves from the
spacing in the spectroscopy signature
you can actually tell the length scale
at which different proteins that tether
the spectral network of the red blood
cell to the phospholipid bilayer
membrane are broken and the reason you
get a change in fluctuation is because
different proteins are being slowly
destroyed in the connecting points
between the membrane and the
cytoskeleton and that's directly
reflected and you can quantitatively
analyze this we've also done experiment
that I will not describe where you can
actually send add ATP or deplete ATP
from the cell and we can actually show
that ATP has a huge effect so now I go
back to the controversy between one
group talking about ATP having no effect
another group talking about ATP having a
big effect because they were looking at
two different parts of the cell when you
look at the whole cell you find that
both are right the techniques were right
the conclusions were right except they
were looking at different parts of the
cell so that was resolved by this and
there is a lot more detail underlying
this which which I won't get into this
talk now let me go to a very different
disease which is sickle cell anemia so
there is a there is a whole range of
complications that arise out of sickle
cell disease the main point is that in a
normal he
more globin when you have globular
molecules you have a disco site shape or
a biconcave shape of the red blood cells
in the deoxygenated state and the oxygen
partial pressure is low people with a
sickle cell trait they develop more of a
linear molecular chain a long inflexible
chain that costs that leads to the so
called classic sickle shape of the red
blood cell so you have to multiple
effects the shape itself is not
conducive to deformability on top of it
you have differing of the cells that
leads to changes in the formability
people with sickle cell disease
different densities that you can get
within the molecular structure and the
hemoglobin can lead to different
responses on top of it you have
increased saito adherence which also
makes blood flow more difficult the
consequence is a variety of counterpane
episodes in some case of stroke organ
damage swelling in hands and feet and
this is an example from the web that you
can see in a child what can happen
because of sickle cell disease so the
question would be what can some of these
newer tools and technologies help with
doing this so you can look at it at
different levels people about starting
about four or five years ago started to
look at that at the macroscopic you know
tons of micrometer scale blood vessels
but lot of the action takes place in
this region where you need to go to
smaller dimensions so we hypothesize in
with respect to these experiments that
underwent well control clanky and
hypoxia condition the only drug that's
approve fda-approved drug for this is
hydroxyurea so patients with hydroxyurea
treatment and patients who have been off
hydroxyurea what is that what are the
kinetics of self cycling and unsettling
and what are the ideological changes can
we come up with better quantitative
estimates of these episodes that
patients face so that's the objective of
this so the one of the questions is
can you make the blood sickle in vitro
the sick of patients plug sickle in
vitro so the next slide shows our
experimental setup that was designed by
our postdoc Sarah do who's now on the
faculty in University of Central Florida
so this is the device we built where we
could control the oxygen partial
pressure consistent with what happens in
vivo so we can make it sickle unsecured
do the control timing etc we can do it
with different drug treatment so we can
look at drug efficacy assays on the
patient's blood but outside the human
body we can do different therapeutic
interventions to this and these are
micro to these units are all in
micrometers so these are micro channels
that we fabricated using the same
technology that we use to make computer
chips so the next slide is a video but
before I start the video let me describe
what it is so this is the blood sample
from sickle cell patients and initially
in the video you're going to see a
normal oxygen conditions and a few
seconds into the video will slowly start
to decrease the oxygen partial pressure
as the partial pressure decreases you
will see increased sickling of the cells
and then will after some time will
slowly start to reintroduce oxygen and
you'll see the unsealing and in fact a
time for unsick lling it turns out is
one-tenth of the time of cycling and
there are a lot of things one can do
with respect to this so this video now
so this we start with normal oxygen
conditions now we take oxygen partial
pressure you can see we reduce a partial
pressure you can see sickling now so
this is the patient's blood outside the
body it starts to cycle and then in a
few seconds we're going to reintroduce
this is fed up of course this video a
few seconds we reintroduce oxygen and it
springs back to its original shape so
what is the consequence of that in the
human body I want to demonstrate that
with the next video before I show the
video and we let me describe what what
this experiment is so we create our
obstacle course so we rounded it off
because there are sharp corners cause
problems damage to the south so we got
cleverer after the first experiment so
we rounded this off we send the red
blood cells through here from the sickle
cell patient now then we start to reduce
oxygen partial pressure and what you
will see here is what happened cells can
go through this quite a bit when the
oxygen level is when you have normoxia
conditions when you I hypoxia condition
the ability of the cell to go through
these obstacle courses significantly
diminishes show them this video clip so
you can see cells going through without
any problem under not normal oxygen
conditions by the way we benefited quite
a bit from dr. Greg Kato who's the
hematologists at state and UPMC in this
collaboration over the last few years
and you'll see slowly one by one they
start to get obstructed at they even at
the entryway and you'll see in a few
seconds more and more of this happens in
this experiment this is in vitro and so
this gives us a tool we are actually
working within several different
hospitals around the country on
different for example controlling
hypotonic city for the red blood cell
adding water these are that a lot of
these tools have been around for quite
some time how effective are they are
they really and can we quantify them
with these kinds of experiments so for a
number of experiments that are ongoing
right now with respect to these
particular expertise so one of the
things we can get out of these
experiments is delay time of self
cycling versus density fraction from the
patient's blood and also sickling sickle
fraction of hydroxyurea on hydroxyurea
and other kinds of therapeutic
intervention so this is
just a summary there is a lot more
detail that I won't go into let me come
to the last few minutes of my talk and
finish with two examples so going from
the cell levels down to the organ level
one of the organs in the human body
that's affected by cell deformability
which is sort of a filter for defective
cells especially red blood cells is the
theme and whether it's malaria or sickle
cell disease the mechanics of the screen
plays a huge role and it's a very
complex topic but the screen has the
smallest fitness test the most stringent
fitness test for the human red blood
cell in terms of the so-called inter
endothelial split between endothelial
cells in the spleen I won't go into the
geometry but it's a you can model that
using computational biology tools in a
very rigorous way but i'm going to show
you an experiment that is being done
jointly between institut pasteur in
paris and our group and the experiment
is the following dr. pierre buffet who's
a scientist position he does isolated
perfused humans clean system when
somebody has benign pancreatic tumors
when in order for the surgeon to access
the pancreas in some cases you need to
remove the screen when you have access
to the fully functioning normal human
spleen you can do a number of
experiments with the screen outside the
human body makes we go experiment what
Pierre and his group have done over the
last 45 years is not only to study
things like how the malaria parasites go
through the live humans clean outside
the body and use our computational
biology tools to calibrate their
experiments for example we know that
blood pressure we know the pumping of
the heart what is the pressure
differential I had often behind a solid
red blood cell as close as it go through
the body what is the pressure different
in the humans clean how does it pass the
fitness test we have no quantitative
understanding average so through peers
experiments extreme or experiments on
real humans clean and our experiments
and computational models we've been able
to guide their not only work in this
area but they've also developed and
patented a synthetic spleen a synthetic
splain made of two metal base and the
beach they run experiments with malaria
parasites with a synthetic spleen with a
human screen so we have connected that
with our experiments of their symptoms
that explain so that we can guide the
design of their sins that explain we've
also done accommodate three-dimensional
model of the real human spleen if you
could show the top image so this is our
user color coded for strain contours and
you can see how the cell goes through
the synthetics please a live human red
blood cells and the bottom right figure
if you click on this thank you that
shows how this the red blood cell is
likely to go through the inter internet
material slit this brings to one of the
most fundamental questions of nature
there was a paper published in 1968 a
wonderful paper by two people carnem and
Burton that claimed that the volume an
area of the human red blood cells is
determined by the smallest blood vessel
in the human body so they measured the
surface area for red blood cells they
measured a volume of a red blood cell
for large numbers of patients healthy
patients I shall see people with its no
diseases and and they came up with a
theory and a model showing that the
reason the area to volume ratio for red
blood cell is a certain ratio is because
it's determined as by the smallest
opening in the human body so this was in
the 1960s they didn't have the benefit
of the tools that we have or the
computational power that we have so we
decided a couple of years ago because
now we have experiments on the real
humans plane we have computational tools
we have all kinds of wonderful nano
tools we can actually ask if that is
really true so last year
we published this paper together and so
this is the work all these points here
are the data points that canim and
Burton published in the 1960s about
twenty years later another group Gifford
at all came and published and showed
that the surface area of a healthy red
blood cells the volume of a healthy red
blood cell should follow this rule then
they claimed that the the determining
factor for the area to volume ratio for
human cells red blood cells in a healthy
human is determined by the by the small
blood vessels so we decided to put that
to test using a simple mathematical
model where we could predict the inter
endothelial slit as the determining
factor and showed in this paper last
year that it's not the smallest blood
vessel is actually the slit in the
spleen that determines the area to
surface ratio so this is the
experimental data from their work the
dash line is this equation this set of
equations mainly this equation and all
the this purple color is a fully
three-dimensional computational model
called dissipative particle dynamics
done in collaboration and with a group
of people at the Brown University in
their math department and my group and
group at MIT so you can see that this
sort of provides a bound now you can
take it to other diseases so if you have
sickle cell blood it should fall outside
of this range if you have Sarah
psychosis if you have a ellipta
psychosis if you have asian / Los I
ptosis those diseases should be abnormal
so this equation and this computational
tool now provides a guide post on
surface to volume ratio as a marker for
potential one more factor in disease
Diagnostics I just want to make a
statement with respect to this so this
paper that was published in the National
Academy of Sciences proceedings last
year this is in relation to the
editorial that the operate that I had
yesterday or the letter to the community
that art was mentioning I just want to
you wear all these people came from Igor
15 is a russian mathematician who got
his PhD at Brown University in applied
mathematics he now works in the
bioinformatics Institute in Basel
Switzerland Zhang Li Peng came from
China did a PhD in Texas did a postdoc
at MIT he's a professor at notre dam
George Canada cos came from Greece is a
professor of mathematics at Brown Pierre
buffets of French clinician scientists
working in Paris ming dao came from
shanghai and i came from india this is
the team that has worked on it and we
work on foot in four different countries
right now I just want to make that point
about how science progresses the last
example with which I'll finish relates
again bringing science and engineering
for a completely different problem my
third disease class which is isolating
rare circulating tumor cells in the
human body so this work has benefited
enormously from collaboration with
professor Tony Huang who until recently
was a faculty member at Penn State
University and since last July is been a
faculty member at duke in their bio
medical program in North Carolina and
Bing so let me explain the base the
rationale for this work as many of you
in the audience know better than I do
there are so many clinical applications
with respect to circulating tumor cells
are a very very complex topic their
shapes are different the properties are
different and what you do with them and
how well you capture them and it's
sometimes it's like finding a needle in
a haystack so the intention of the
experiment that I'm going to describe is
not to change current medical practice
but if we can add one more tool to the
list of options that's available to a
clinician or a cancer doctor or a
patient we probably increase the odds of
somebody surviving
few more years that's the spirit in
which these experiments are done
potential applications are being able to
capture them and also capture them
unaffected will lead to early cancer
diagnosis the all-time disease
progression monitoring tumor stage in
criteria personalized drug treatments
and susceptibility tests and treatment
targets about a year ago there were
three hundred and five clinical trials
in the u.s. that are probably much more
now the four major types of experiments
that are being used around the world
very broadly fall into the following
categories centrifugation way
essentially you spin and then try to
isolate mechanically of course it's a
high g-force and that can cause damage
to the cell and its properties fax a
fluorescence-activated cell sorting is
another technique a tagging technique
magnetic beach and then different types
of labeling or filtration whether it's
electrical chemical biological or just
mechanical filtration through a poor all
of these are their benefits they also
have their drawbacks but one of the
critical factors is that if you capture
a cell however you capture it are you
altering the properties of the cell
because of the method you use to capture
the south in other words the artifact of
the experiment all of these techniques
have artifacts so for a practicing
clinician or somebody who diagnoses the
disease it's very important to know
whether what the artifacts are so we
decided that because ultrasound is so
commonly used hundreds of millions of
times all over the world for many many
decades safely on humans can we take
ultrasound as a technique at the cell
level so that we can actually capture
the cell so the technique involves the
following we use something called
standing surface acoustic wave so
essentially we there are some things
called IDT interdigitated transducers
which are in our cell phone and there
are two IDT so this is a u.s. dime so
the marker these are the idts this is
the device that we are you
thing compared to 10 cents so that's the
size of a dime to calibrate it so these
idts send out surface waves so if you
have a fluid flowing through let's say
first the fluid as particles in and say
plastic particles and as the fluid flows
through as you generate a surface wave
it causes what is called a radiation
pressure on the particle in this case a
polymer particle so you have four forces
that you're pushing the fluid with a
pressure so there is a forward force
there is a drag force that's preventing
the fluid drag that prevents the fluid
from flowing you have something called
the buoyancy force that place to lift
the particle and you have the
gravitational force that tries to pull
the particle down for a microfluidic
device the buoyancy force almost exactly
balances out the drag the gravitational
force so only in the horizontal
direction you have forces net forces so
the fluid is flowing in this direction
if you have a particle the particle gets
something called radiation pressure so
now I can do to control experiments I
can take two particles of the same
material but slightly different size so
I can take a slightly smaller particle
let's say eight microns or three microns
and a five or ten micron particle and
them together the two particles will
experience two different forces from the
acoustic wave the larger particle will
go in one direction the smaller particle
will go another direction I can separate
them now I can do the following
experiment I have two particles of the
same size but slightly different
material the physical properties are
different because the physical
properties are different the radiation
pressure will be different and therefore
one particle will go in one direction
another particle will go in another
direction I can separate them so we did
that we did that with an efficiency of
more than ninety five percent so once we
did that then we thought okay that is
the case we can do something better if I
have healthy white blood cells and if
you have cancer cells there's both the
difference in size and different
property I should be able to separate
the cancer cells from the red blood cell
so we first started with cultured cells
to see if the experiment works with a
hypothesis works so we took breast
cancer cells cultured cells like mcf-7
and we took cervical cancers of HeLa
cells and we spiked the concentration
fifty percent healthy cells fifty
percent constant cancer cells we sent to
mix them sent them through this we could
separate the cancer cells from the
healthy cells quite accurately still it
doesn't solve the problem because it
doesn't solve the problem of circulating
tumor cells because you want to find one
in 100,000 south then we went to Hershey
hospital in Pennsylvania because we had
some initial connections and
collaborations there and we got blood
samples from three breast cancer
patients and we took blood from the
patients and data series of experiments
of course they diagnosed the cancer
using other techniques and we were able
to capture the circulating tumor cells
out of this and we could capture one in
100,000 self till the technique is not
accurate enough of fine time it's still
primitive it's still at a lab scale it's
not ready for prime time but we this is
what we demonstrated last year so this
is essentially the technique let me show
you the video so here you see the in the
top you have cancer so this is a
cultured cells you have cancer cells
going this way healthy white blood cells
going in this direction we can turn the
surface acoustic wave on or off and we
get different results here are the
examples of various experiments we did
in collaboration with Hershey hospital
and this is just a last year last year
and a half these are the breast cancer
cells hela cells etc we were able to
successfully these are the number of
cells we were able to capture how many a
one in 40,000 cells one in hundred
thousand cells we were able to capture
still it may not be good enough but
equally we've been able to show that we
are able to capture these cells and
these cells at least based on the
experiments we have so far I cannot
confirm that hundred percent based on
the experiments we have so far it seems
that the cells are not affected by our
experimental technique
because the acoustic wave is benign on
the south it doesn't alter the
properties of the south there is no
other contact that's involved here
unlike the other techniques that I
described so this is this remains to be
seen so with that I want to conclude
with a few observations so hopefully
I've shown through a variety of examples
that we have possibilities for
understanding human diseases at the cell
level using a variety of experimental
and computational tools in some cases at
the arden level we have potential
benefits fundamental mechanistic
understanding diagnostic capabilities
potential for novel therapeutics and
this is a field where 15 years ago most
of the bio engineering departments
around the country including at Pitt and
Carnegie Mellon they started about 15 20
years ago to come into full swing and in
the last 15 years since we started our
first work the number of people working
in this kind of a field that the
intersections has really grown
exponentially and hopefully this will
bring together hitherto disparate
communities in ways in which we have not
seen and there is a quite a good
possibility for us as drug efficacy
essays as well as I mentioned this work
would not have been possible without
collaboration from a large number of
groups this doesn't even do justice to
all the people from whom this work has
benefited first and foremost I want to
acknowledge Ming for for being part of
all of this work a number of people at
CMU have been engaged in different
aspects of this work a large group over
the last 10-15 years in Boston at UPMC
and pit I adrian lee working we're
working with him on the CTC part of this
because yo sadowski another idea
especially with respect to acoustic
waves and its implications for placenta
research Greg Kato from Holly Tony Hwang
George kanina dockers at Brown
University we benefited enormously from
the medical school both at the national
university
singapore and nanyang technological
university without their help this work
would not have been possible ten years
ago and a number of folks have helped us
in this work institut pasteur and
fathers has been an absolute necessity
for us and it's a wonderful group of
colleagues we are benefited and most of
this work has been supported by NIH and
my work is not supported by NSF because
I've been bought from applying for
grants from NSF is there's a punishment
for public service oh so I want to thank
you for your attention thank you
well because of the lateness of the hour
we're going to hold the reception for
super up in the lobby and those of you
who have questions or comments can have
at him there but first before everybody
leaves we have a gift for sughra so the
medical school chair
[Applause]
our daughter is a is an MD who's now in
pediatrics in New York City and she
calls me the useless kind of doctor so I
couldn't do one thousandth of what she
is able to do that's all go upstairs
[Applause]